[Music]
I just interviewed the cast of Captain
Underpants and ask them some super fun
question so now let's hit the streets
and see if the fans can guess what they
said I asked to Ed Helms if you've been
hypnotized Kevin Hart what would he make
him do now like a kitten run around LAX
in his undies or slam dunk a basketball
yeah like a kid if you're going to send
someone you have to like it was the most
embarrassing thing I probably go to the
ended run around in sunny I probably
make him run around LAX airport baggage
claim where there's lots of paparazzi in
tighty-whitey you're correct yeah you're
really good at this
do you one day do my I asked Kevin Hart
if he could hypnotize Ed Helms what
would he make him do aerobics covered in
honey near beehive or go back to doing
stand-up comedy feel like there's a
little more irony in this one aerobic
that feels more creative Alec to me I
would make a go back to Doris and you
know mad know each other from stand-up
comedy in New York to see him go back
and embrace stand-up comedy again will
be pretty dope you're correct about did
you even know what hums did you ever
know I had no idea he said that he would
make you strip down your underpants and
run around the baggage claim at Elliot
see those what so you guys know what
Captain Underpants says right yeah What
did he say
yeah
it's like his call has them for years
how long do you think ed Helmes can hold
that note
okay clarification the lot part or the
entire thing that's that's a big
difference in be surprised you can
actually go for a pretty long time
Oh
Oh
[Music]
I either passed the test where I passed
out and I'm now in a dream state run to
middle-earth yes workers and that as
they say in Hollywood is a wrap
[Music]
you